[Aplausos]
pues quiero contarles también un poquito
de de dónde vengo no quién soy y cómo
llegué a esta serie del chapo ya toda mi
carrera como actor obviamente pues bien
soy el menor de cuatro hermanos puros
hombres mis papás son de guerrero mis
abuelos también yo nací en la ciudad de
méxico pero estoy registrado en guerrero
antes se podían hacer otro lado y
registrarte en otro lado era locura
ahora no bueno creo que creo que ahora
no se puede pero yo soy oficialmente
guerrerense en mi sangre guerrerense
pero nací en la ciudad de mexico
mi abuelo era poeta y escritor tenían
tenía dos libros publicados y eso fue lo
que me marcó en mi vida como actor
yo estaba una escuela en un colegio
donde había solamente un certamen de
declamación forrado había un ser también
mamá nos metió ese certamen y fue mi
primera vez que yo estuve en un
escenario como un monólogo a final de
cuentas yo no sabía que quería ser actor
estaba en un escenario con una poesía
aprendida que mamá no se entrenaba con
las poesías de mi abuelo
estaba yo pues tenía cinco años la
primera vez que me subí al escenario
cinco años con un auditorio lleno y
concursando ya para ver quién recitaba
mejor me acuerdo de la poesía porque la
pose era muy triste era triste triste
triste hasta el título era porque los
reyes magos no llegan a casa de los
pobres
era de mi abuelo pero era súper triste y
total que empiezo empiezo a los 5 años
yo a recitar la mamá preocupadísima esas
que mamá a la mamá se preocupan de que
lo dijera bien porque se la saben mejor
que tú entonces éste empezó a recitar y
en el clímax en el clímax de la de la de
la poesía se me olvida
y empieza a llorar claro la gente dijo
wow está conmovido
empezaron a aplaudir y de repente vuelto
al público y veo que están llorando
conmigo y yo dije ah caray algo sucede
aquí entonces yo empiezo se empieza a
improvisar empecé a improvisar mamá de
este niño que está haciendo
empezó a improvisar y luego conectó con
el final de la de la poesía y la terminó
me bajo yo creo que llaman y hoy llego
me siento primer lugar marco de la oyó
hay en mi mamá
me aplaudió pero fue el primer momento
en el que yo aprendí y sentí lo que era
improvisar lo que era estar arriba de un
escenario de lo que era era era tener el
aplauso las luces en frente de ti no
sabía que quería ser actor pasa el
tiempo y me voy a otra escuela donde
había un taller de actuación
si la actuación me hago teatro una
comedia musical me acuerdo que me dieron
el personaje principal que era el pino a
árbol 4 algo seguramente
ya era el pino y tratar que le hago el
agua
este personaje y el maestro me dice es
que marco tú tienes talento para para
ser actor yo pues me encantó a los 12
años supe que quería ser actor llegué a
mi casa le dije en mamá mamá quiero ser
actor de una mano si como no
o bien no me creyó luego yo agarré y le
dije más más quiero que mientras a unas
clases de actuación yo ya no quiero
estudiar me ganaba así que como no forma
que yo soy yo quiero exacto yo voy a
ganar dinero como actor y ya era muy
malo y más aprobé reprobé como todas las
12 materias era mi récord 12 materia es
muy malo era muy malo para la escuela
pero había encontrado había encontrado
la luz en el camino en el túnel que era
la actuación me meto la actuación voy a
una web o ver antes quien tenemos google
y nada esas cosas me las voy a la
sección amarilla
yo tengo 40 años se rían voy a la
sección amarilla y busco escuelas de
actuación que intenten veo la chava
virginia fábregas mi esquina familias
perfecto con 12 años y yo digo ok donde
está lo por teléfono dónde están
me quiero inscribir y está como a una
hora de mi casa yo hago hora y media en
transporte público metro minutos ante la
ciudad no era tan peligrosa agarre me
subí al metro me fui y llegué pedí
informes llegué con mamá le dije mamá
aquí está quiero ser actor mi mamá no se
sorprendió me dio una organizada dijo
que hasta porque te bajas pero se dio
cuenta una cosa me di cuenta que una
cosa yo y ella que las cosas se
consiguen como yendo saliendo de tu casa
tocando puertas si tú quieres demostrar
que quieres hacer hacer eso pues yo fui
y le dije mamá quiero estudiar le traje
todos los panfletos y todas las
propagandas y me dijo bueno pues vamos a
el niño quiere ser actor pues con
apoyarlo eso fue una gran virtud también
y mis padres que siempre me apoyaron
siempre siempre fue mi papá fue mi
primer mi primer fan y mi mamá cuando
pasa el tiempo yo llego a otra llega a
los 18 años estos 18 años eran padrísimo
porque tiene que decidir qué quería ser
porque ya se acababa el bachillerato y
mi mamá me decía mal con todo él quiere
ser actor yo sí pero me decía pero
porque no estudias otra carrera
esta carrera dijo porque te vas a morir
de hambre no vas a hacerla si yo creo
que te ve frustrado no te quiero ver
deprimido yo más que uno que está bien
para que no molestara le dije que iba a
ser abogado
otro día
me dijo yo las quemadas ya no quiero ser
el psicólogo porque se parece a la
actuación porque también analiza los
personajes el psicólogo
y mi trabajo que en psicología llegó
casi en el último mes del bachillerato
no ha sido ninguna escuela para pedir
informes en ninguna universidad no te he
visto hacer nada
dije es cierto a más me fui otra vez fui
a una escuela patricia reyes spíndola
estuve tres años ahí llegué con los
panfletos otra vez con mamá le dije esta
es mi escuela esta es mi universidad
quiero ser actual mamá mamá y hockey
también apoyaron los mismos mis padres
pero va a contar una anécdota lo difícil
que es vivir a una casa de puros hombres
ellos en el menor
yo estaba en la escuela de patricia
reyes spíndola y un par muestro me dice
oye marco para ser actor hay que bailar
y cantar yo para que yo quiera ser actor
no quiero sacar mi disco ni quiero
entrar en el 97
no no yo no quiero yo quiero actuar
no es que los actores 30 preparados para
para para cantidad para bailar y saben
separar un escenario tiene que saber
bailar yo que me entendí la razón me fui
a la escuela que se llama
emma pulido que estaba a la vuelta de la
otra escuela llegó a la escuela me dicen
y me escribe
me dieron el uniforme era un leotardo
y pues era complicado y yo no estaba
acostumbrado y me dan un suspensorio
sando que un suspensorio para que
soportara aquí para que no se juegue
movimientos extraños cuando estás
bailando es un calzón especial de los
hombres para protegerlo entonces hago mi
clase llego a mi casa estaba todo sucio
obviamente sudado lo pongo en la ropa
sucia como a la media hora
soy un grito si quieres está mi mamá ya
si no llega a todos mis hermanos así y
dije ahorita me van a molestar me van a
decir de todo llegó y le digo que es mi
mamá es de mis clases de ballet
[Aplausos]
y mí y mis hermanos me bolton a ver pero
la vuelta y se fueron
pero que respetaron completamente mi
trabajo
fue uno de los momentos más especiales
porque mis hermanos me dijeron en ese
momento sin decir nada te apoyamos
sabemos que esto es raro pero
apoyamos te apoyamos y entonces pasar
tiempo también vamos a para adelante
bueno pasa el tiempo y fíjate que me fui
a estudiar después me fui a estudiar a
cuba en cuba conozco otro maestro me voy
de ahí me voy a nueva york en nueva york
que estoy estudiando un año y me toca en
las torres gemelas
mi mamá me habla meses dígito tienes que
regresar te está ya está muy peligroso
ha regresado méxico me voy a españa a
estudiar la carrera de literatura y arte
dramático con una especialización en
interpretación
estoy cuatro años haya pasado del el
terrorismo que de allá del 11-m mi mamá
me llame sectores talibán o qué
como la culpa de eso me queda terminar
la carrera de estuve cuatro años haya
regreso a mexico y empezó a hacer
telenovelas mucho teatro cuatro siglos
del siglo español mucho mucho teatro
teatro teatro y me acuerdo que en una
ocasión mi primera vez que llegue a la
televisión me dieron una escena de 10
segundos 10 segundos tiene que recibir
en salomé la novela salomé me siento yo
era un ministerio público y tiene que
recibir a los tres protagonistas que
llegaban a ciudad porque está encerrado
yo creo mucho abundó pueden pasar era
todo lo que decía
era todo lo que decía de repente le dio
al director director qué te parece si
estoy comiendo torta una torta ya traigo
una torta al actor viaje para que dure
otros 10 segundos
no joven
no puede pasar claro
tiene que ser algo para que durara más
y si efectivamente cuando la vemos la ve
la tele esos 10 20 segundos vuelto a ver
mi papá y estaba llorando estaba
llorando en papá y un momento que dice
por eso se actor
sí claro porque tocas a la gente tocas a
la gente nosotros actores me encanta
hacer personajes y actuar y ahora
hacerla de matón del narcotraficante y
pistolas y luego eres un ganador y una
siesta padre
pero pero lo más bonito de esta carrera
es poder tocar al corazón es poder tocar
a la gente puede hacerlos sentir eso es
lo más bonito lo más bonito de esta
carrera y no lo cambio por nada es ese
momento especial
bueno después pasa el tiempo y mi fan
número uno en mi padre muere de cáncer y
fue una situación complicada para la
familia porque nos venimos para abajo
después pero entendimos que así era
parte de la vida porque cuando se va
alguien también llega a otras personas
llega mi hija y mi hija trae a torta
bajo el brazo
bien a los seis meses hago un casting
para el chapo
y me quedo entonces yo voy a contar la
historia de cómo me quedé con el chapo
llegó llegó al casting que lo estaba
comentando antes que cortar y lleva el
casting y les digo había volteo para
esto me llama el jefe de casting y oye
marco queremos que hagamos un casting
para el chapo yo quiero y me parezco
pero hoy y que quieren que haga un
casting para el champú y saber si te
parece si es posible para saber rasurado
déjate el bigote punto esta camisa como
de narco y ahora le para el casting
ahora
llegó al casting llegando a como
llegando al casting y estaba diego luna
y yo sí no
[Aplausos]
yo no puede ser que me llamase más
quedan él
y obviamente ya llegué este dice mi casa
sin superbien
me fui como la semana me llamaron otro
callback otro callback 4 kóvacs un mes
de casting y tras ellos pues me quedé no
estoy encantado
creo que creo que el problema de hacer
un personaje como esto es tener mucha
responsabilidad nosotros no queríamos
hacer ningún héroe ni tampoco un villano
queríamos hacer un humano y por eso
mucha gente me pregunta que es es que se
siente ser el chapo pues entonces no se
siente nada yo simplemente ese actor que
él trató de interpretar lo más honesto
posible con mucho respeto para que la
gente lo vea y vea mi trabajo sin que
ustedes hagan su propio criterio de
valor yo tengo que hacerlo yo no puedo
juzgar a mi personaje si es bueno o malo
yo soy actor no puedo juzgarlo entonces
mucha gente me dice
por qué haces tantas series de narcos
porque hay tantas series de narcotráfico
porque es nuestro día a día hoy
cuántas películas de la segunda guerra
mundial han visto un millón hoy es
nuestra realidad y ustedes como una
frontera la frontera más cruzada el
mundo lo saben saben lo que ha pasado
también esta ciudad lo que estamos
pasando en esta en este mundo creo que
también es una denuncia ciudadana está
esta serie donde tratamos de ser lo más
honestos y lo más inteligente y no
hagamos apología ni burla de todos estos
temas está tenemos que sacar a méxico
adelante con con series de esta calidad
de esta calidad porque porque son series
que vale mucho la pena sanar a la liga
al nivel de cualquier serie del mundo
no hagamos el y apoyemos al güero alto
de ojos azules con dinero con coches con
mujeres y que sea el rey y que llegue
mañana me pregunte mi hija o mi sobrino
yo quiero ser como él
difícil pongamos un poco más de
conciencia y yo de verdad que después en
el chapo ha sido todo una aventura sigo
ya trabajando ahora salís tengo ya con
un proyecto en hollywood estoy ya
viviendo allá estoy muy contento y bueno
las cosas van cambiando poco a poco
siempre piensen siempre todo lo que
piense en todo lo que pasa por su mente
se vuelve realidad
háganlo busquen su vida busquen sus
proyectos en la gran casa nadie
de verdad no lamente a nadie y si pasa
por tu mente pasa por tu vida muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]